hello time for the press preview then a
first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages this good friday we'll see
what's making the headlines tonight with
polly mckenzie
and alex dean there they both are
speaking to them in a couple of minutes
first of all let's take a look at some
of those front pages starting with the
times writing that the uk's successful
kovid 19 vaccination program will
inspire fundamental changes to the way
that the nhs
works the daily telegraph leads with
potential government plans for
certificates which could mean no
quarantine and minimal testing for
people traveling abroad if they've had
the jab
while plans for international travel are
shaky the daily mirror says the easing
of lockdown has sparked a staycation
stampede
the daily express takes the angle of
families soon getting the chance to be
reunited including care home residents
meeting their grandchildren for the
first time
here's your saturday guardian looking at
the massive backlog of operations the
nhs will face
due to the pandemic with weights of up
to two years for
vital surgery
on to the sun tv star mark wright says
kovid has ripped his
family apart that's the story on the
front of the sun
the ft reports the cost of an
independent scotland has risen
due to brexit and the pandemic
and flake news is the headline on the
daily star referring to the cold snaps
sweeping over much of the uk
this easter weekend and we're joined
tonight by polly mckenzie
and alex dean great to see you both uh
this easter
weekend uh polly let's get cracking
shall we uh no pun intended
um front page of the times will stop you
getting
sick says nhs chief uh that's good to
hear
just fill us in on what this means
well it's a really interesting story
obviously the vaccine rollout has been a
huge success
for actually quite conventional public
health measures
old-school public health is about
protection from disease
uh tracking down diseases and
vaccinating people what's interesting
is that actually public health in the
21st century
had been for a long time much more
focused on what they call
non-communicable diseases because
actually that's what kills most of us or
at least it did until this pandemic
obesity uh lifestyle diseases uh cancer
smoking
and so public health has been focusing
on those things
and oddly enough they seem to be
suggesting that they are going to stop
us getting sick that they're inspired by
the vaccine program
but that they're going to continue with
that kind of 21st century public health
interventions around
prevention of course prevention is much
better than cure
and some of these examples are inspiring
and interesting
some of them are a bit odd they're
suggesting that bin men
may if they notice you haven't been
putting your bins out
somehow make that a flag to local health
uh
providers in order to make sure that
somebody calls around to check on you
i'm not sure that bin men who certainly
in my experience aren't very good at
putting the bins right
back in front of the right house are
quite the right people
to be doing local health surveillance
but certainly you know the macro
objective
of focusing on prevention wherever we
can rather than cure is a good thing
but the reality is when you get into
this kind of lifestyle diseases stuff it
is
actually much more controversial than
this headlines suggest
yeah alex just before we move on to uh
to vaccine passports
and the like just give me your thoughts
on this well this is sort of the
comes full circle for the nhs because
when it was created
our national health system was meant in
part
not just to heal us when we are sick but
to keep us well they had a dual mission
when it was founded and in time that
second part of its mission has dropped
away
because of course you have to prioritize
and focus on um what your
budget allows you to do but also because
of concerns about paternalism and the
state telling you
what to do and this in new initiative in
some ways jives against the announcement
that we've seen that public health
england after this epidemic is going to
be split in two
and so we're going to have the one that
deals with pandemics and you know that
sort of real
health alerts on one hand and the kind
of nanny status tell you
what you can eat and drink and bully you
to exercise on the other which
would be at least more clear-cut well i
suppose at least they're being honest
about their intention
okay all right well let's move on to the
vaccine passport uh then
uh we've got a lot to get through uh
inside the times page eight and nine
uh bosses can tell staff no jab means
no job polly of course a huge amount of
controversy today
um about plans yet to be announced um
what's the paper saying here
well again there's still quite a lot of
uh unclarity here if that makes any
sense
they are basically standing behind this
idea that
they can't legally stop pubs or
employers or whatever it might be
asking to see vaccination certificates
because you know
in a free society companies should be
able to do whatever they like
as long as they're not discriminating um
but on the other hand
the government would have to essentially
facilitate
access to that information the
suggestion in this article is the nhs
app where you might be able to confirm
that you've been vaccinated
but then in this way it gets a bit kind
of confusing they're also suggesting you
might be also you'd be able to use
the nhs app to prove that you've got
natural immunity
i don't know how you're going to prove
that with an app but or
that you've recently been tested which
of course we know is already happening
at the moment where people are showing
negative tests for example before
hospital appointments
or before um going to some schools so
again it all seems like a bit of a
soupy mess and the reality is that if
the government does get involved in this
it's going to be
horrifically horrifically controversial
particularly because
more than half the population still
hasn't been offered a vaccine
although many of the population do
actually think the kobe passport uh
system isn't isn't a bad idea
um alex uh why don't we move on to
the uh front of the telegraph uh foreign
holidays
for the vaccinated i mean the whole
thing is becoming
something of a mess isn't it we should
get more clarity on monday when the
prime minister speaks
yeah we should but i have to say from
what we see so far i'm with the 70 odd
members of parliament who think
vaccine passport's a bad idea or
whatever they're going to call it a
vaccine certificate
not only because of the reasons they've
rightly pointed out about the potential
for discrimination between people
um because of such a system but because
either it will be paper-based and you'll
have a certificate people can rampantly
fake in the way that documents have been
faked in this country
forever all much more likely to link
back some central database
and governments have always shown one
they never keep data for one purpose and
then
uh don't use it for others they always
use it for other purposes and
furthermore government's always
shown they can't build a system without
it breaking or losing the data or both
so it seems to me to be a terrible um
idea and furthermore it does seem to me
that we had a debate in this country
about id cards we called them that
rather than vaccines
yeah but it's very different alex isn't
it we're in a completely different
situation
i mean they answer me this question if
i've had the jab
uh or i test negative or i have
antibodies
in in me and i can prove that through
this app and i go to the pub that's fine
so the only people who can't go to the
pub are people who have
kovid who shouldn't be in the pub anyway
i mean where's the issue with that
if people who've gone to the pub are 90
90 of them are vaccinated and 10 aren't
people who are at risk on your logic
aren't those who are vaccinated are they
it's those
who haven't been uh vaccinated and in
fact the stage um on the i didn't get a
chance to speak on one of the other
stories jonathan but
um the member of sage who's been
speaking out about this today on
uh a number of outlets argues against
having vaccine certificates for
precisely the reverse logic that you
just use which is
the false positive perspective and the
potential for a false belief in 100
immunity which isn't there you'll have a
false sense of certainty that's what
you'd have down the pub if you had had
the job wouldn't it
yeah okay good point uh let's move on to
the front of the daily mirror polly um
i'll tell you what we all need a holiday
don't we and there is going to be a
staycation
stampede when is it a week on monday
that we can we can go to self-catering
accommodation
in our own household yeah and
and i'm sure lots and lots of people
have already booked are massively
looking forward to it
the challenge is that lots of uk people
tend to go on holiday abroad partly
because it tends to be quite a lot
cheaper
and with so few people able to travel
abroad because you have to
you know basically you can't go on hot
day you have to have a very legitimate
kind of family caring or business reason
uh
a lot of people trying to cram into not
that many holiday properties
which means that prices have been
surging and you know whether it's
campsites or
or or or sort of self-catering cottages
they are just
absolutely packed to the rafters so it's
really hard if you haven't got something
booked to find that holiday
yeah i think it's almost cheaper to buy
a second home in cornwall than it is to
rent one for a week
at the moment there are so few left um
and uh just finishing with the front of
the daily
express um i mean this is a nice
headline alex at long last families can
share the love yes super finally we're
going to be able to
visit care homes and i think that this
is another area where we've seen
uh to use the phrase that's been used by
the rebels today as some discrimination
between
people because in care homes people are
being treated differently on the basis
of their age not their condition
not their health but guidance backed by
law has been saying some people can and
some people can't
go out or see their loved ones and so
forth that's not right
in my view and the sooner we allow
loving families to be able to see their
elderly relatives in care homes the
better
polly and all of them yeah yeah where
the resident has been vaccinated and
their visitor has been vaccinated it
seems to me that absolutely the priority
is connection yeah um have you got a
staycation book polly
uh staying at home which is of course
the only real kind of staycation if you
leave the house to go to a holiday
cottage that's just
a uk holiday oh you're such a pedant but
you're absolutely right
um alex polly thank you both for the
moment
coming up flake news is the headline in
the star as uk's mini heatwave
is followed by a cold snap we'll talk
about that
if you're watching the press preview
still with me paula mckenzie and
alex dean events in washington happening
too late for the first editions
of most of the papers but
alex perhaps you could reflect on what
has happened in the states tonight
uh the very sad death of uh police
officer
william f evans in this uh attack
yeah it's a great it's one of the things
that sadly happens sometimes when news
breaks and the
newspapers miss what many of us will
think of the biggest news
first and foremost terrible thing to
have happened and i know we'll all think
of
officer evans and his family the broader
point that i would seek
to draw is that politicians who by the
way generally go into public life for
the best of reasons wishing to do well
have been on the receiving end of a
coarsening in public life and a
corrosive sort of
dismissal of of them and a treatment in
the media and in
social circles as if they are dirt and
sometimes that encourages
a broader attitude of disdain and
contempt and the hard end for that
is attacks on them both verbal and
physical
and we should sometimes remember we've
seen this happen in our country
too all too recently and all too
terribly both to police officers
who defend our democracy not just
defending politicians but defend
democracy
and also to politicians themselves so we
shouldn't look at this and think we're
immune from it
we're not yeah president biden and the
first lady saying they are heartbroken
over the death of officer william evans
uh he served for 18 years in the capital
police force and i'm sure
uh that story will be on many of the
front pages of the later
editions um back to uh this evening
and the ft poly uh price of scotland
breakaway
rises um independence to create a fiscal
hole says
uh a new ft study
well i mean economists have always
argued that
there would be huge financial impacts to
scotland
because uh you know being part of a
larger union enables
tax money from you know london
the south east are all across the uk to
fund what is often higher need
in scotland and this study which the ft
has done
suggests that because of brexit which
creates you know additional kind of
trade barriers
and because of changes around the fiscal
circumstances the price of scotland's
uh breakaway or an attempt to be
independent would be even greater they'd
have a bigger fiscal black hole
though to be honest uh as a result of
coronavirus we've all got such large
fiscal black holes that i wonder whether
in the end this is what shifts public
opinion in scotland
or doesn't because as we saw with brexit
having a bunch of economists
screaming at you saying you're gonna be
poorer doesn't necessarily
shift people's perspective because if
it's about sovereignty
lots of people choose sovereignty over
you know a few hundred pounds this way
or that way
yeah talk about people's perspective uh
alex the salvation poll was interesting
wasn't it in
recent days alex salmon on just 3 which
is a pretty dismal performance uh when
it comes to independence the
the yes no vote on 50 50. i mean despite
everything that's gone on in the last
few weeks it doesn't really seem that um
things have moved one way or the other
particularly well i don't see why people
should change their mind on independence
either way based on
arguments between two of the leading
proponents uh for leave which had gone
on
in their own psychodrama as individuals
for some uh time but i
would take polly's point and say that i
think it's absolutely right that these
points about
economics don't shift public opinion nor
actually to be fair to the smp and those
who urge um
independence should it if you wish to be
a sovereign country
and that is your overriding goal then
why would you be um frightened into not
voting for that because
um whether the treasury claims you're
going to be several thousand pounds
worse off about several thousand pounds
you might not even have
or based on the statistics we saw in the
brexit campaign
you're not going to believe the numbers
anyway when you the thing that really
concerns you and matters to you is the
principle
so really on this occasion i'm afraid
it's only you two that are getting
hounded by the cybernets online tonight
and not me but don't worry they'll come
for me next time
and polly where do you see the debate
over scotland going in in the next few
months
i think it's really difficult um i i
mean
it doesn't look like alex almod is going
to have a huge impact on the outcome of
the the scottish election um you know if
the snp do manage to get that
uh majority then they you know i think
it's perfectly possible they will call a
a wildcat referendum just to sort of see
how it goes and the politics between
the the uk or england uh our uk i think
we would call it if scotland were to
leave
uh are just really difficult we we have
been moving you know announcing plans to
move civil servants to scotland
to suggest you know how much the country
means to us
it's been really difficult during the
pandemic of course for ministers to
visit
to give that sense of of community and
solidarity which is so important
i i you know i i don't really trust
myself to have an opinion on this
because it would break my heart so much
to see scotland become independent
that i find it hard to really engage
with
it actually happening that makes me a
bad commentator though sorry
no i i love our union nothing i said was
meant to say that i would wish to see it
happen i simply think that
if that is the commit the principle in
which you are
you're politically committed economists
arguing that you're going to be x worse
off because like oil's dropped in price
there's an argument that was used or the
brexits happened or because of
coronavirus
i think most people look at public
finances and say if we can take
the crate ring we just had over
coronavirus we can take pretty much
anything yeah okay and uh let's just
finish with the front of the daily star
uh flake news polly we'll have a full
look at the weather in a moment what are
they saying
apparently it's gonna snow this easter
weekend which i'm definitely not up for
but i have got on a nice cozy jumper
so i also just planted grass seed in my
garden so i'm i'm extremely disappointed
to hear
this news i can't think of another
easter where it snowed i'm sure people
are going to remind us immediately how
long i am but i cannot think of another
easter when it was actually snow
1980 on my christmas 1880
um yeah i had my shorts and flip-flops
on for for about three hours
uh this week before relenting and going
and getting a sweater
alex polly thank you both very much
indeed thanks very much